last fall we made some bowling
animations they were slightly offensive
however since then it's become a bit of
a thing to make slightly offensive
bowling animations it's kind of kind of
viral online it seems like this is an
idea that people can really relate to
everyone has gone bowling at some point
in their lives and seen one of these
animations how do you make something
offensive that's also funny and accepted
versus just pissing people off thinking
about this a lot because i can think of
lots of terrible things it's simple it's
easy it comes naturally the problem i
face is is it a personal reflection of
myself you know it's funny because it's
bowling balls we're good how close can
you get to actually offending somebody
without defending somebody see that's
true art i thought i found the line in
the last round that was nowhere near
it was humbling in case you're wondering
no jordan's render never did hit the
internet it is stored securely in a
vault here at corridor and has never
seen the light of day we have it in cold
storage right now good luck
the most successful renders were the
ones that looked like actual bowling
animations from 1997 which were probably
made on software from 1994. so with that
in mind i encourage all of you to
capture the aesthetic as much as
everything else if you have shadows make
sure they're just crisp as hell yeah
make this feel like this could pop up on
one of those old crt tvs yeah just
sitting up there with your score like it
should be indistinguishable from every
other bowling animation of the era all
right guys meet here same time tomorrow
to see our animations i'm getting
started right now oh okay well then i
will let's go
well it's time
i think the first thing i need to do is
open up my old project files maybe you
know recover some of those assets
remember ionic animations i was his like
fourth or fifth subscriber ever just
from that little shout out
he's got 26 000 subscribers i'm blown
away that's incredible good job you guys
one of the ideas i was thinking of was
like
i don't want anyone to hear my idea so
come with me go to the bathroom with me
is this
the idea i have is that the bowling ball
is going down the lane the camera's
lined up so that we see the back of the
bowling ball and the ten pins there like
walls would come down with little shower
heads on each of the walls around the
pins with a cage in front so they're
locked in and the bowling ball turns
around and there's this mustache
i don't know hey man i'm not used to
trying to be edgy
so you know as a canadian i think we
have a reputation for being real nice
and i'm gonna try to be offensive it's
against my nature but maybe get a laugh
you know maybe some people be offended
probably will smith um i'm sorry big
willie styles i'm sorry dude i'm going
already dude
look i could do police brutality i could
do racism mike you do bigotry i could do
russia i could do ukraine i could do
will smith slapping chris rock but
there's just one classic one i've always
wanted to do is on my original list that
i made in like 2019
uh an airstrike gone wrong it looks like
they're carrying weapons and so someone
calls it in uh super jacked up slightly
offensive see that's what i'm saying
it's like honestly this is pretty pc if
you ask me i'm actually really
struggling with this old school render
style because i'm like is this supposed
to look bad i guess so you know like
pretty pretty gang looking so used to
this unreal thing where i'm just like
[Music]
you know now i'm like oh yeah assets
textures like
so
i got an idea and maybe it's too
offensive maybe not you know it's hard
to say until you make it so right now
i'm trying to do my layout just build my
scene my environment my lighting get my
characters built once i have that all in
place i'll kind of position it and i'll
just knock out my animation and my shots
i'm working at 3ds max i'm really trying
to stay true to the aesthetic doing
really simple low polygon if something
feels like a shortcut i make a point of
doing it so i purposely take shortcuts i
purposely don't do a good job i know
that someone's going to have their
feelings hurt by this somewhere in the
world which makes me sad hopefully the
amount of laughter brings
the net positive for humanity so we'll
see we'll see these thoughts were heavy
upon my shoulders while i manipulate my
polygons
jordan
you okay i'm just so
offended right now you're offended
they're in there making these
offensive bowling animations
they think that that's the most
important part the animations that play
at the end of when you strike or
something no no no they have it all
wrong
bowling it's it's not about the
animations it's it's about the shoes
and listen the best shoes for any
situation are vessies
so i'm going to go in there and show
them the true meaning of bowling
bessie shoes
hey hey stop what you're doing it's not
important besties are 100 waterproof and
weatherproof did you say 100 waterproof
i did go ahead put them on try them out
pour some water on them
all right now take that shoe off
it's totally dry yeah
no way see vessies are made from a
dimetex material that keep your feet
cool in the summer and warm in the
winter hey hey matt come on come on
what what you know what's not offensive
what's that not using animal byproducts
for your shoes see bessie's 100 vegan
okay and they use much less material
waste than other shoes here have a pair
that's crazy
look at this this is actually these are
nice i want these i want these in my
life
hey do those feel lightweight and
breathable to you yeah they breathe like
the animals that are still alive right
that's because they are and they come
with an anti-bacterial soul we'll never
smell your feet matt all right finally
jeez these messes are so clean i can
lick them
oh you licked it dude you actually did
taste like the animal free not that
super offensive stop it how many styles
are there that is a great question
jordan there's actually so many styles
you can wear them in the gym you can go
on a hot date you can go hiking you can
wear besties wherever you want i love my
besties i wear them when i work out i
wear them when i'm bowling and i really
encourage you to start wearing them as
you make these offensive bowling
animations i really really want you guys
to think of the true meaning of bowling
it starts with bessie
i've never thought about it like that
understandably because i don't see the
correlation
but these aren't great shoes so yes e
two vessy so this might come off as
offensive but i actually have to take
these back these aren't really up for
grabs but hey listen
if you do want a pair though head over
to bessie.com quarter crew for 25 off of
each pair of vessies so these ones that
you just tried on and that you loved 25
off each pair but it's my birthday yeah
yeah that's why i'm coming in here at
your birthday present 25 off of each
parents happy birthday to you guys happy
birthday to me
25 off vesey.com corridor crew
so that has come for all of us to gather
to watch the slightly offensive bowling
animations round two wait niko what
happened
broke my collarbone i fell off my bike
look this is slightly offensive on the
title this video proceed further it's on
you the aesthetic is truly where the
heart of the comedy lies right it's like
wholesome it's innocent and then
combining it with this subject matter i
mean
that's where we get the magic is bowling
first
let's go
[Applause]
i'm out here
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
[Applause]
so fenner included a copyrightable song
so thanks for subscribing to the website
go to cordova.com check it out
that i love how everything you did was
kind of slow motion and it felt like a
bad dream just the whole time very
offensive in canada look i learned from
my past mistakes okay this is my second
bowl my first bowl was a gutter ball so
i'm kind of relying on this one to save
my turn
now i'm too scared to watch it hit i'm
just gonna look up at the monitor and
find out what happened oh
wow
[Music]
don't be scared
dealing with pinheads is right up by
so you see it not too bad right really
good also i like the very hyper
realistic human legs like with the right
anatomy for the musculature and
everything yeah i made them extra extra
greasy yeah for the viewing public
you're welcome it just felt right to
beat the child to death
[Music]
now you get the name i'm passing the
mantle to you i'll peter jordan i don't
know if i want that i'll be here call me
ball beater jordan ball beater beans
i'll beat your balls
all right let's take a shot down the
lane here i just have some time over the
weekend i wasn't here for the kickoff
but you know i wanted to get something
in
it looks like i was able to find all the
pins
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i thought i found the line man
oh you did it you did this perfect look
quentin tarantino gets a pass if he gets
a pass so do you honestly we didn't see
anybody get shot we're assuming that he
was you know yeah he could have missed
dean good work with the render hey it
looks really nice is that animation or
is that like this oh the
guy walking in is me
in my kitchen deep motion just going
how are you gonna bowl with your injury
all right so it's actually uh somebody
already went and they knocked over all
but one of the pins and they just gave
me the balls of jokes i'm just gonna
grandpa this ball
down the runway or whatever it's called
i got the pin all right nice i picked up
this
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow wow that the gentle
clever touch
my god you it's so offensive yet not a
single thing was shown
could you say that you were bowling for
columbine
[Music]
yeah why
i don't get the joke i don't get it i
don't get it i get it
i i guess i'll follow that one up yeah
let's see what you got i uh i'm okay
okay
come on don't be shy it's just bowling
i know what you want
you're looking for a very particular set
of skills
[Music]
that's good yeah
yeah yeah it's the sound bites from
taken with the face of qui-gon jinn
referencing schindler's list wow that's
layered oh okay i realized the thing to
make this funny was just to give liam
neeson just jacked limbs so i just like
i ripped some random 3d model of a jack
dude just cut out the body attached to a
ball
greased them
i'm just like so excited right now i
love that we're all getting this janky
render style
i'm on a roll and you you go and you're
like
[Music]
nine
okay
[Music]
is much worse than him killing an entire
chicken
wow sam well done
i'm offended
i'm sending this video to julian assange
that's pretty offensive man
it's pretty offensive i want to see
something that's offensive right now
okay i got you i got it
i just pulled
i just pulled
300. all of them
oilers
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what a nice like little like talent
cleanser from the other videos to really
set a new tone the kkk and the
israeli-palestinian conflict and a giant
dick and
i see it
now you know i am like a little bit
offended and a little bit worried which
is perfect so yeah you guys i mean i
think we all did a good job and we
showed ourselves a round of applause
should we
i think we'll be fine but i think it
really comes down to the individual on
this one
[Laughter]
come on guys
bowling animations we gotta get these up
on an actual bowling alley so subscribe
for the next video which will do that